[Musique]
à new york le printemps dernier cette
scène a révélé l'ampleur de la pandémie
des victimes enterrés dans une fosse
commune sur une petite île au large du
bronx
si l'image a choqué la pratique n'est
pas inusité depuis la fin de la guerre
de sécession
hors thaïlande est devenue le lieu de
dernier repos de plus d'un million de
personnes des victimes d'épidémies comme
la grippe espagnole mais aussi des new
yorkais sans famille aux moins nantis
las vegas elle six autos nous donne
rendez-vous devant le dernier immeuble
où a vécu son père avant de mourir
atteint du sida au début des années 1990
elle si se souvient d'un homme isolé
ségrégué ça s'est fait de guéret faute
d'argent pour l'organisation de
funérailles
sa famille a dû prendre une décision
déchirante remettre son corps à la ville
de new york qui l'a fait enterrer à hors
thaïlande où il repose de manière
anonyme
il a fallu des années à sa fille avant
de pouvoir lui rendre visite
les est difficilement accessible encore
aujourd'hui impossible de s'y présenter
sans rendez vous sans se heurter à une
porte fermée et des barbelés
mais les ruines d'édifices datant
parfois du 19e siècle ajoute à l'aspect
lugubre de l'endroit puis pour rappeler
que ray allen n'a rien de cimetières
ordinaire jusqu'au début de la pandémie
des détenus de la prison new-yorkaise de
rikers était responsable des
enterrements
depuis quelques mois une idée circule
celle de ferme c'était le passé trouble
un monument question de rendre hommage
aux près de 25000 victime new yorkaise
de lakovic 19 mai mais linda hunt
responsable de l'organisation hors
thaïlande project crois qu'un éventuel
mémorial voir un parc national devra
répondre un mandat plus large notamment
mot est en tout cas où elle ne pas
seulement rendre hommage aux victimes la
pandémie les a tous ceux qui sont
enterrés à houthalen depuis un siècle et
demi et dont l'histoire est souvent
tombé dans l'oubli
[Musique]
depuis des années son organisation
multiplie les efforts pour retracer leur
histoire
et faciliter l'accès à leurs tombes aux
membres de leur famille
déjà une amélioration est à l'horizon
à partir de cet été la responsabilité de
lille sera transférée du département
responsables des prisons à celui qui
gère les parcs ce qui pourrait
contribuer à un changement de décor elle
six autos y voit une bonne manière
d'apporter un peu d'humanité aux
familles comme la sienne pour qui le
deuil n'est pas complètement achevé
[Musique]
oui